so
the irreversible damage is the one i
think you're talking about the book
exactly right exactly so so let's go on
that let's go even deeper with that on
what you're saying so
i'll give you a story i'm in the army
i'm 18 19 years old
i love women like i can't have enough of
them like i was like you know i i was
greedy extremely greedy right
and i was a capitalist i i wanted to
experience everything and anything i
could
one day one of the guys at our unit says
i found the sickest club but i can't
tell everybody about it because we could
all be kicked out of the army if they
find out what club this is i said what
club is it's a gay club
so it's a gay club yeah but i'm telling
you it's the best club in america i'm
like it's the best club in america
where is it at it's in nashville
tennessee get out of here no one's gonna
put the best club in nashville tennessee
i'm telling you it's the best club in
nashville tennessee what's the name i
can't tell you i just have to take you
there first all right so at this point
of the game
thank god i trust this guy because he
was my workout partner
so i asked him i said listen i mean i
partied with you i've never seen you
like men he says no no you don't
i don't like men but you got to go here
with me you'll see why it's unfair
i said okay let's go so we go to the
club so we take one of our friends it's
four of us now two of our friends
by the way all of them till today uh
were in contact so we go to the club
first of all women are there with the
intention of they don't want to be
flirted they want to be left alone right
so they're kind of going they're saying
oh
gay men i love gay men because they're
this they're that so there's only a few
straight men there
we're four of them okay so the market's
on our side we're winning here right
but we go in and obviously it was
exactly what he said
it was unfair it's like the movie a
wedding crasher where the scene
where owen wilson goes to meet uh uh
will ferrell and wilfer's like my wheat
loaf
he says man i'm not going to weddings
anymore i'm crashing funerals you gotta
see it's like it's not even fair because
you know all this stuff anyways
and obviously there's a part of it
that's not funny but that's humor movie
you know we all watch wedding crashes
funny
but one of my friends a guy comes and
flirts with them
now for me it's like listen it's cool i
get along with everybody i'm very
comfortable
but i have no interest but one of the
guys comes and tells one of our friends
and he says
so you like men no i like women
he asks a simple question afterwards how
do you know
and i got to tell you this question of
how do you know
confuse the living crap out of this guy
so we leave the place we got a one-hour
drive back it's two o'clock in the
morning we've had 20 beers in us we're
driving with you know alcohol levels
that's not appropriate at all
the entire time he's like how do i know
like what are you doing
but i pat i really don't know what do
you mean how do you what do you
fantasize
but this is what's crazy about it you
know what ended up happening
this guy experience just to find out if
he knows or not
that that's what he had a gay encounter
just to answer that question
just to answer that question whether he
did or not
so the part i'm going to you with this
obviously there's humor behind the story
but it wasn't humorous on the drive back
i'm just i just remember being hammered
and we're cracking up about it
but the point i'm trying to make to you
is if media
and tv social if they have this much
power
if they just put it in your mind to say
how do you know
cocaine isn't good for you how do you
know you're not a trans how do you know
you're not this how do you know you're
not that
how do you know we don't know how do you
know communism doesn't work how do you
know
how do you know how do you know you're
like maybe i don't know maybe it is
euphoric maybe it is utopian type of a
life maybe i should try
that's what i mean when i say the
marketing today the amount of influence
they have
is it really changing the way we're
wired because we're questioning stuff
about ourselves that maybe we just don't
know
i don't i i wish marketers had that much
influence
they don't uh now in your in the case of
your friend maybe he had some
you know some questions that he needed
answered but i think that if you were
asked
a hundred men uh who are
you know about heterosexuals how do you
know
you don't want to get sodomized by a
turkish hairy guy how do you know
they'll say well because i don't
fantasize about that i
basically i've lit my entire internal
life of fantasy
has been rooted in fantasizing over
beyonce and not about a turkish hairy
guy
sodomizing me so so i don't think it's
that mysterious and i don't think any
marketing guy is going to convince me
to go to a gay sauna uh you know
sodomy so so i think that that's on your
friend
but i will mention something uh that is
scientifically interesting to what you
asked there is something called sexual
fluidity
and it's actually it's a it's a real
term whereby
so if you look at women they're much
more likely to be
fluid so for example a woman could be
completely
committed to being a heterosexual woman
she really prefers
men but you know in that uh
dorm at wellesley on that cold evening
night when
my girlfriend and i were really tight
and we started wrestling a little
lesbian session broke out now
i say that you know in a jocular manner
but women
have the capacity to be a lot more
fluid in their sexuality whilst
completely
being uh you know committed to being
heterosexual
it's much much less likely in men and
and the data the scientific data
suggests that
very few men wake up on a tuesday and
say today
i have to kind of think inside do i want
to be
clobbered by shakil o'neal or is it
going to be beyonce night
no i think i'm going shaquille very few
guys maybe your friend was one of those
but he's a unicorn so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye